I love your outfit I loved your little
butt jiggling I was like there's a lot
of booty look and fire dancing like
flower opening the show how do you think
it went tonight I think it was really
good it was kind of nerve-wracking to be
the very first one out there but it was
also such a surreal experience and I
can't wait until next week to be back
and better yes yeah so you got the
highest score for a female female on
your partner tonight you know a girl
power we like that girl power how do you
feel about that and what are you going
to bring she's a beloved national
treasure I know the pressures on use it
I'm worried now because everyone loves
her I'm like oh god I can't disappoint
everyone make her wear an ugly costume I
don't want bad choreography I want good
music I'm trying my hardest and she's
doing a very good job
it's hard being in the room with now
she's awesome I saw when I was coming in
here a bunch of your batch friends we're
here how cool is it to have everyone's
support it was so awesome to see some
familiar faces out there in uncharted
territory for me here and they've just
been so supportive and I'm just really
thankful for the friendships that have
come out of this long year it's been
really great them well leave it to
Dancing with the Stars we're about one
day in and we've already put you
together in a showmance I was is that
true yeah no that's what the internet
says Oh
Tom mentioned it when you weren't
talking you weren't listening finished
yeah that was so excited I was still
like she killed it I'm so happy yeah you
know I was there but we're having a
great time and oh man fall in love with
dancing dancing is it super annoying
well I know you're gonna be on the stage
tomorrow DT so they're gonna ask you
this but is it so hard to be under the
stars never even been like oh my god
you're dancing
great are you in love with someone yeah
actually the rest of your life yeah
because I think everybody has had this
journey with me
and it's been focused on finding a
person that I'm going to spend my life
with but right now that's not what I'm
focused on and forced to spend the next
few months with me you have no choice
Hannah where were you guys when you
heard that Christie Brinkley had fallen
and she was out of the competition
honestly uh I think we heard one sailor
was already rehearsing so like three
days ago and we're like what is
happening it was it's incredible that
sailor can come in she is the sweetest
person ever
it's a I introduced myself the first day
and she's like Alan I'm like oh my god
hi
last question it's a personal question
that will probably never air but I would
like to know like the costuming
department like how dancing to the Stars
is Hannah beasts going oh like oh you
want like I want all the things oh sure
oh no no I mean maybe covered with with
some sequins and they're in the right
place but no I go in full-body party Oh
make me look like a pro and then I gotta
just dance like one yeah
[Music]